i'm joseph gordon levitt and now the 40
year old is making
a big tv return and reflecting on the
journey and the blessings that got him
here i i feel so grateful for the life i
lead i
i found the perfect woman for me and we
have our kids i have two wonderful
parents i get to do work that i care
about
i'm healthy i'm safe you know and and i
think a lot of that just comes down to
playing luck
i've worked hard sure but i've had some
really lucky breaks
joseph's had quite a few lucky breaks
roseanne 10 things i hate about you
and of course third rock from the sun
which turned 25 this year
oh my my first tv family you don't have
the authority to alter the schedule
i'm in command yeah well i'm in puberty
pal
but e.t first met the actor on the set
of a tv movie back in 1993.
i i try not to really criticize myself
and i don't like to watch
myself like perform because then
you get self-conscious and you you like
i shouldn't have looked that way i'll
try to look
this way and then and then you look like
you're trying to act if you look like
you're
trying to act and then you're not doing
a good job
i think that if i hadn't had some of
those lucky breaks if i wasn't able to
earn a living
as an artist i think teaching is
probably what i would want to do
i love that it's not too late professor
one day
i know i want to do it someday i really
do that someday
is now sort of in the new apple tv plus
series mr corman out today joseph plays
a fifth grade teacher
only problem he's struggling with
anxiety broken dreams and
the sinking feeling that he kind of
sucks as a person but don't worry
jgl's winning in real life he created
wrote composed original songs for and
even directed
eight of the ten episode first season
you feeling less anxious no i'm really
not
what made you put so much of yourself
into this project
probably is the most personal thing i've
ever done and what made me do it is
because
i'm a film nerd you know and i love
acting i love it to death but
i also i'm fascinated with so many
different parts of process camera or the
lights or the costumes of the production
design
when you're an actor you don't get to
play with all those things you're just
focused on on your job
it's a very gratifying delight to get to
play with all those tools and
and really tell a story
you